this is the American dream time-saving
superhighways it's the crown jewel of
our transportation systems the whole
interstate highway system over the next
two decades is going to need to be
replaced but there is no possible way
the current I wait trust fund could
begin to do that project at the end of
July Congress is scheduled to pass a new
highway transportation bill about the
best case scenario we can imagine is
that it will be something like a 275
billion dollar monster covering six
years even more likely as a worse sir
case scenario which would be yet another
temporary patch to try to plug up the
National Highway Trust Fund which has
been essentially empty for years Bob
pool has been working on this problem
for 25 years as director of Reason
foundations transportation policy
program he testified in front of
Congress about this just last month Bob
this is for you bob thanks for joining
us and talking to us so much so if we
lived in a sane world abab pool run
world what would be two or three things
that a transportation bill would include
well for the current situation is what I
told the House Ways and Means Committee
first thing they should do is to
reinforce rather than undercut the user
pays principle when we originally
created the high Federal Highway Trust
Fund it was entirely paid for by per
gallon fuel taxes that people paid and
the sole purpose of it was to build the
interstate highway system over time of
course that's a nice flow of revenue
Congress kept every time they
reauthorize the program and the taxes
they thought of more things that could
do so it's become over the years a kind
of a general transportation public works
program including four things that had
nothing to do with highways yes nothing
to have highways like bike trails and
ferry boats and you know everything
sidewalks and so the state do TS have
become dependent on it and it's a big
part of their budgets it's really only
about six percent of the total 50
billion it's actually going to build or
rebuild major highway and bridge
projects around the country I mean I
think that is a complete distortion of
what the program was set up to be its a
50 billion dollar program today with 40
billion dollars worth of gas
revenant so the patch they're talking
about is always coming up with some kind
of general fund money to supplement
what's in the trust fund so they don't
have to cut the spending the first thing
I told them was using general fund money
undercuts the user pays principle it
really is the best safeguard we have
because if the money that is user pays
is exempt from budget cuts its pristine
it's it's safeguarded the more they
undercut that principal the more they
make it a crap game of how much money
there's going to be so cut to the chase
and restore it to being a user pays
system that means of course either raise
the gas tax which we generally don't
favor or cut the size of program so my
number two recommendation was you've got
40 billion dollars worth of user
revenues you've got to make it a 40
billion dollar program because there's
not any political support really for
raising the gas tax and that means
setting priorities given that this is a
federal program it's not should not be
in all things to all people program
they've got a reef they should be
refocusing and on the interstate
commerce functions which was the
original rationale for having a federal
tax and a federal program and let the
states recover the idea they're
responsible for all the other roads and
things and if they want to do things
like sidewalks well that's their problem
it should not be Congress's problem and
so that's in the beautiful Bob pool
world that we don't get quite living in
the lived in reality of Congress what
are we likely to see how is this bill
going to stick us with yet more well I
don't see any likelihood of a six-year
bill emerging this year and nobody
seriously does either now I mean
Republican posturing of the Republicans
last I looked hold both branches of
concert right haven't they had time to
think about this oh they think about it
but all they've done the last few times
is come up with short-term they
reauthorize the last time for two years
and that expired last september's so
we're now almost a year I know in a few
months it'll be a year of temporary
extensions they're going to almost
certainly do another temporary extension
probably till the end of this year
coming up somehow with enough general
fund money from somewhere to hold it
over so that the spending doesn't have
to get cut between now
the end of the calendar year it's just
another temporary solution to a
long-term problem that doesn't solve the
problem am I not correct in that I agree
that's my assessment certainly they
still going to have the same problem
next year if they want to do any kind of
a serious bill where's the money going
to come from if they don't cut the
spending to match the size of the
revenue describe briefly what are some
of the more ridiculous places they found
money to kind of patch over the highway
trust they did something called pension
smoothing they change the rules about
tax deduct ability of pension spending
and minutes it's actually a stupid thing
that makes the pension systems that are
our tax exempt less sound which is a
problem in general already they're not
very sound but it gives them a short
term budgetary saving on paper plus
little other things they have fudged
there's a fund as part of the highway
trust fund called lust leaking
underground storage tanks it's a tiny
piece of it but there's enough money
there they took the money out of that
and put it into regular host lust money
this is lust money fill the gap to part
of a gap this isn't but they've used up
most of these things I mean they can't
repeat them so they're getting more and
more desperate now what they're looking
at and even our good friend long time
reason reader Paul Ryan the chairman of
house ways and means is seriously
interested in some kind of repatriation
of us firms overseas profits that give
them some kind of a break on the tax if
they bring the money back who's that at
least a big chunk of that is nothing has
absolutely nothing to the interstate and
so I have a lot of respect in general
for Paul Ryan but the very first thing i
said was basically counter to that by
saying you should not be doing any more
bailouts like this you should be
reinforcing the user pays not
undercutting it further what are we
losing besides sanity and approach to
basic budgeting here what is the
interstate highway system losing as a
result yes way that we do this well the
interstate highway system started in 56
most of the rest were open in the 70s
all of them were designed with a 50-year
service line that means if you properly
maintained the pavement over the years
it will last 50 years before it has to
be ripped up and replaced and what is
that going to cost so the whole
interstate highway system over the next
two decades is going to reach any
50 years life and need to be replaced
basically and also a lot of quarters
don't have enough lanes so forth I did a
study Reason Foundation study two years
ago that estimated using prudent
conservative calculations about a
trillion dollar net present value of a
20 year program to rebuilt the whole
system other estimates are higher but
there is no program no identified
funding source and no possible way the
current as structured Highway Trust Fund
could begin to do that project so the
other thing that I recommended to the
waist Means Committee was that Congress
needs to bite the bullet and allow the
states to use toll financing to start
reconstructing and modernizing the
interstate system it's incredibly
valuable resource it's the crown jewel
of our transportation system and it's
going to start falling apart if we don't
have a major effort that's going to
rebuild it and modernize it and so the
federal government right now is an
obstacle it's an obstacle because when
they passed the interstate highway
program they put in a ban on using tolls
except on the ones that were
grandfathered in like the Pennsylvania
Turnpike because they were all ready for
their you leave or enter the super my
way a pool gate but anyplace else in the
country it's illegal to use toll finance
to reconstruct them for whatever reason
but that's an obstacle mr. Poulos a year
a big fan of tolls and I got to tell you
folks back home in Texas most likely
drive you off the road part of the
problem is that the toll roads like the
Pennsylvania Turnpike seeeeee have
turned be turned into cash cows by the
legislators and politicians in those
states they don't charge just holes that
are enough to properly maintain and
reconstruct they use the money for all
kinds of other things so you have
opposition therefore from triple-a and
from the trucking industry to any
further expansion of talking so my other
part of the recommendation is that
Congress if they going to do this they
have to put conditions on it so the
tolls would only be pure user fees money
could not be spent one penny on anything
except the capital and operating costs
of the rebuilt interstates and that
would have to be guaranteed at the
federal level and at the state level one
day we will live in a bobb pool
transportation world I hope so my book I
hope will be out next year outlining
what how to get to that world thank you
for you toiling all these years and for
explaining the latest to us pool for
reason TV I'm Matt Welch